this true essence of things now has the
character of not being immediately for
consciousness on the contrary
consciousness has a mediated relation to
the inner being and as the understanding
looks through this mediating play of
forces into the true background of
things the middle term which unites the
two extremes the understanding and the
inner world is the developed being of
force which for the understanding itself
is henceforth only advantage this
beating is therefore called appearance
for we call being that is directly in
its own self a non being a surface show
but this is not merely a surface show it
is appearance a totality of show this
totality as totality or as a universal
is what constitutes the inner of things
the play of forces as a reflection of
the inner into itself in it the things
of perception are expressively present
for consciousness as they are in
themselves that is as moments which
immediately and without rest or stay
turn into their opposite the one
immediately into the universal the
essential immediately into the the
unofficial and vice-versa this play of
forces is consequently that developed
negative but it's truth is the positive
that is the universal the object that in
itself possesses being the being of this
object for consciousness is mediated by
the movement of appearance in which the
being of perception and the sensor
sensuously objective in general has a
merely negative significance
consciousness therefore reflects itself
out of this movement back into itself as
the true but croire consciousness
converts this truth again into an
objective inner and distinguishes this
reflection of things from its own
reflection into itself just as the
movement of mediation is likewise still
objective for it this inner is therefore
for consciousness and extreme over
against it but it is for consciousness
the truth since in the inner as the in
itself it possesses at the same time a
certainty of itself or the moment of its
being for self but it is not yet
conscious of this ground or basis for
the being for self which the inner was
supposed to possess in its own self
would be nothing else than
nothing else but the negative movement
this however is for consciousness still
the objective vanishing appearance not
yet its own being for self consequently
the inner is for it most certainly
notion but it does not yet know the
nature of the notion
in this section 143 which is quite long
there's a lot going on in here
and in the two very short almost
staccato sections following at 144 and
145 Hegel is going to once again bring
us to a very important point of
transition not only for this particular
section but also for the phenomenology
as a whole in this particular paragraph
this term that I've put into capitals
the pearance is particularly important
there shining in German now when we see
this term one thing that you want to do
from the beginning so I want to say this
by way of preliminary don't read into it
everything that you've got from other
philosophers regarding appearance and
reality as opposed to appearance you
will be playing off something similar to
that but within the Hegelian system
itself you could say that appearance
plays a vital and somewhat different
role than it does in other philosophical
systems where appearance is in I'm not
going to say just you know the same
thing as reality it's not you know
Bishop Berkeley with you know to be is
to be perceived or rather to appear but
appearance has a dynamic active quality
to it it's not merely what's a
perception and Sensibility taken you
notice I've got negative here because
he's going to talk about those are only
able to grasp a sort of negative aspect
to appearance and one way to think about
that is in terms of grasping what is
static in in the appearance and that's
given to those modes of consciousness
when we're looking at things through the
lens that the understanding that we've
done so much work to actually attain
provides us what we're going to see is
there's more going on in the picture so
let's with that in mind pick up where he
starts he says the true essence of
things right or the the true background
of
what it is that we we were trying to get
at this entire time and what we did
arrive at in the previous paragraphs is
now revealed to us as something that is
in some way estranged from our distance
from the understanding or consciousness
as a whole so there is the inner beating
of things remember in the last paragraph
we had that you know the the notion or
the concept of force was not fully
developed as notion and we have this
kind of splitting not only between
forces and each other that we see in the
play of forces but also between
consciousness or the understanding and
the interviewing of things that is going
to get worked out further in this this
paragraph so he goes on and he says the
true essence of things now has the
character of not being immediately for
consciousness the consciousness is aware
of there being some sort of decision
some sort of division between it's some
sort of distancing between itself and
the object that it's trying to cognize
on the contrary consciousness has a
mediated relation there's something in
the middle something that is not
necessarily interfering but more
revealing something that's offering a
way in to the inner being and as the
understanding looks through the play of
forces the mediating play forces into
the true background of things
what Hegel is saying is if consciousness
now grasping itself reflexively as
understanding wants to look into the
being of things the inner being of
things beyond what it had before it has
to do so through the mediation of the
play of forces so it attends to those
not just for their own sake because
they're interesting but because it wants
to get at what's there what we were
calling earlier the unconditioned
Universal what's what's most real what
is he's going to use this the true right
the
truth of things now how does this happen
he calls us a middle term that unites
the two extremes we're going to see him
actually talking in the next section
about a syllogism and what will go into
what that means but the middle term is
the one when you're carrying out a
process of inference or reasoning that
allows you to connect up the other terms
so it's not just some sort of medium
like a lens through which you're seeing
something or a recording device rather
it's the the part that allows you to
connect these things together at all
it's doing some active work the play of
forces here and he says the two extremes
the understanding and the inner world
not the inner world of the person but
the inner world of the things that we
actually see the things that are subject
to the forces the play of forces that
were witnessing is the developed being
of force which were the understanding
itself is only the vanishing now we've
been seeing him use this term vanishing
quite a bit and he's gonna keep using it
throughout this so we probably need to
stop for just a second and take stock of
that term why does Hegel keep talking
about things
vanishing they never really do vanish
they remain on the page they remain
within our consciousness when we're when
we're doing the you know the Galleon
process the dialectical movement of out
of hey bong of you know this is sort of
synthesizing things into greater holes
were supposed to be conserving something
of that so that they never truly vanish
but from the standpoint of the the
consciousness which is developing itself
dialectically it appears to and
vanishing can mean losing its sense of
necessity it can mean being revealed as
merely being a composite or a play of
other things so the unity that was there
originally and was was you know you
might say there is a show to use when
the terms that he's going to use very
soon turns out not to be the case when
we were looking in the earlier sections
in for example since certainty and we
were talking about here and we realized
that here itself which seemed to be
totally concrete you know this here
there were a lot of other hears and that
here became a universal the individual
here was revealed as something that was
vanishing but it vanishes into something
else within Hales perspective right it
never just vanishes off the face of the
earth all together so he says this being
is therefore called appearance being of
the play of forces being of what is
mediating is appearance and he says I
want to make an important distinction
here air shining is not the same thing
as shine what's being translated as show
and now when we think about how we
actually perceive things or how we grasp
them through the understanding it's
possible for us to just simply have
something appear to us or show itself to
us and we take it into account you know
it's something sensible we perceive it
but it's uh it's grasped as something
that's in some ways not of the essence
it's it's in a certain respective losery
right so he's going to contrast
appearance against show he says it's not
merely a surface show it's not
superficial if appearance is really
showing us the interior T of beings if
we can grasp it as something more than
what we typically call appearance which
is just what Hegel is calling show here
he says why is it not it just a show
because it's a totality now when we're
using that term totality what we're
thinking about is not just merely one
thing but a whole bunch of things and
we're not just thinking about a whole
bunch of things you know lined up Willie
with each other none of them important
in the way that they're connected with
each other but with some sort of not
necessarily ordered but or structured
but but certainly connected related
whole a totality is more than just a
bunch of parts throwing together so when
we're talking about appearance as ear
shine on and when we are relating this
to two forces we've seen that forces are
already both you know certainly simple
and unified and in their expression
they're externalizing they become
complex as they move out into the world
of objects appearance also has this play
between multiplicity and unification in
what we're calling totality so he says
this totality as totality or as a
universal as something that is more than
just a particular CF an appearance at
least the way the understanding is
grasping it it is more than just a
particular individual thing that's the
way that sensibility or perception
grasps appearances right but the way in
which the understanding grasps
appearance is more complex we need to
bring to it everything that we've
already learned about universals so he
says this is what constitutes the inner
being of things so the appearance is
what is letting us peer into if we want
to play on words a little bit English
where it's not German words the
appearance lets us peer into the inner
being of things the play of forces is a
reflection of the inner into itself and
so I've drawn this kind of you know
looping arrow right the inner being of
things expresses itself it externalizes
itself through the appearance or the
play of forces but what it's doing is
its really relating itself to itself
this is what it means for it to have
being
yes in the way that something that
possesses interior tea a certain opacity
we're sending almost a little bit sorry
in there and I don't want to sound too
much that way but a certain opacity to
consciousness a certain resistance a
certain challenge you might say to
consciousness come and see what's what's
in here come and see what I've got
so he says the things of perception are
expressly present for consciousness as
they are in themselves as moments which
immediately and without rest stay or
turn into their opposite and here he
talks about this this dialectic that
we've seen many times already you know
the one turns into the universal the
essential immediately into the you know
the unattentive ice versa
but how does that happen that happens in
the play of forces we've already seen
that force can't even remain a unity it
splits into a duality and that duality
is kind of weird because you know we
can't even say which force came first
and which one is the soliciting because
the one that's soliciting turns out to
be solicited and it's soliciting by the
other for so we'd go on and you know
further down down this sort of stuff
that that's all happening here in the
play of forces as the way in which the
inner being of things is expressing
itself for consciousness that's how
things give themselves if we're doing a
phenomenology right so he goes on and he
says the play of forces is consequently
the developed negative but its truth is
the positive the universal the object
that in itself possesses being the being
of this object is mediated by the
movement of appearance in which the
being of perception and sensuously
objective in general has a merely
negative significance so perception
sensibility not going to be particularly
helpful here instead we're doing
something that is you might say
conceptual it is it is involving
universals that the understanding is
able to
again and think about reflect upon and
work with so where do we go from here he
says consciousness therefore reflects
itself out of this movement back into
itself as the truth so consciousness is
doing a little bit more or rather a lot
more than it understands itself to be
doing unless we as consciousness are
watching what's going on
so there's consciousness as the
consciousness that's understanding the
play of forces through the understanding
and then there's the dialectical
consciousness that's that's being
provided by this work which is us
looking on and seeing what's happening
with this consciousness at this gestalt
this shape of consciousness okay so he
says it reflects itself out of this
movement back into itself as the true
but core consciousness it converts this
truth again into an objective inner and
distinguishes this reflection of things
what's the reflection of things this
movement right within things
externalizing themselves out of the
interior T through the plant forces so
that they can reflect back into
themselves consciousness is grasping
this but what it's doing is ending up
putting a kind of barrier
this becomes the in itself this becomes
the true this becomes where things are
really going on consciousness does not
yet realize that in itself is already
over here on this side but there's
plenty of time for that to that
realization to be worked out right this
is the way things typically work for
Hegel so he says consciousness converts
this truth into an objective inner and
distinguishes this reflection of things
from its own reflection into itself just
as the movement of mediation is likewise
still objective for the mediation is
here to play it forces and that is on
the side of things so what we have from
the perspective of consciousness at this
point is that the understanding is over
here belonging to the conscious subject
then there's the world
then there's the
things of the world and the
intelligibility of those things lies on
this side something as a you might say a
lure or a challenge or an opportunity
for consciousness but is not yet
belonging to consciousness
it hasn't been assimilated yet so he
says it's not yet conscious of this
ground or basis for the being for self
which the inner was supposed to possess
in its own self would be nothing other
than the negative movement this however
is for consciousness still the objective
vanishing appearance not yet its own
being for self so you remember how we've
we've talked about things having being
in itself and for itself the inner being
of things has both of those modes of
being as does consciousness but
consciousness does not realize yet that
that inner being of things is not
something out there totally away from it
but rather is already within the scope
of consciousness so he says consequently
the inner is for it's certainly notion
but it is not as yet know that nature of
the notion so this is concept this is
but if this is the development that has
taken place some sort of synthetic unity
unity of what we'll talk about that in
just a moment that's also happening over
here but it's merely as far as
consciousness goes implicit because
consciousness has not yet realized what
is actually going on
within this inner truth as the absolute
universal which has been purged of the
antithesis between the universal and the
individual and has become the object of
the understanding there now opens up
above the sensuous world which is the
world of appearance a super sensible
world which is henceforth is the true
world above the vanishing present world
there opens up a permanent beyond and in
itself which is the first and therefore
imperfect appearance of reason or only
the pure element in which our truth has
its essence
section 144 is deceptively short so you
might be tempted to blaze through it and
145 right after that to try to get to
some meteor portion but there's really a
lot of important stuff going on here
between the lines you can say Hegel
starts out by saying so what we've got
now at this point is the understanding
consciousness through the understanding
he has gotten itself to the point where
it's able to grasp the absolute
universal the universal in the you might
say multiplicity sense where there's
many universals has been reconciled to
some degree with the individual so that
the two of them are no longer in
antithesis or oppose they're no longer
you know
Gagan gazettes set against each other so
he says it's become the object of the
understanding now what happens in that
case first there's a sensuous world that
opens up within the absolute universal
what is the absolute universal in this
case the inner being of things that is
mediating itself for the understanding
through the play of forces through
appearance and so we have a sensuous
world the world in which we we seem to
have our being in which we perceive in
which we eat things in which we talk to
other people in which we watch YouTube
videos and our eyeballs take them in and
our brain you know does some thinking
about them we have this whole sensuous
world world also where if you poke
yourself in the eye it's gonna hurt
right and that is the world of
appearance not a pure an but appearance
there we go
let's start to run out of room on the
side of the chalkboard so this sumptuous
world is now being revealed to us as
world as a totality of show and
the appearance of all of that then we've
seen going on in the last paragraph now
here's where it gets really interesting
Hegel says above this opens up another
world and we're going to see that
throughout the rest of this section
Hegel is going to be playing off not
only two forces against each other which
are more or less on the same level right
not only laws you know as Universal and
as particularized against each other but
also worlds against each other entire
assemblages of things so this is going
to be a really important distinction
here he talks about the super sensible
true well above the sensible now that
doesn't mean that it's totally
unsensible or just simply not sensible
or the opposite of sensible it's not you
know Plato's world of the forms although
it does seem that you know at first
bears some similarities yet but it is in
some way greater than sensible you know
this is where truth resides this is the
true world as opposed now to the world
of appearance so now it starts to look
as if appearance is you know second-best
we have our world of reality we have a
world of appearance this is why it could
sound very platonic Hegel is saying that
all of this is opening up inside of the
absolute universal so these are going to
be connected to each other these are
going to remain connected to each other
in some way they're not going to be
split off and totally sundered although
one you know it kind of looks like that
that's why I drew a divided line rather
than a complete line you know got to
represent this graphically in some way
now here's where another thing comes in
that's particularly interesting to know
we just seem to banish appearance from
the supersensible world which thinkable
also calls a beyond it's it's not
something limited finite like the world
of appearance the sensuous world that
we're able to grasp
remember it's the understanding that's
grasping this and the understand that's
also grasping this splitting taking
place this super sensible world he says
is the appearance and he this is the
same word air China the appearance of
what well this is where it gets really
interesting the appearance of reason an
imperfect appearance of reason the first
imperfect appearance of reasons not
fully developed every says or only the
pure element in which art the truth has
its essence right so but let's linger
with this distinction between reason and
understanding in German idealism reason
and understanding our distinguished from
each other there are there's various
ways to do this
generally reason is going to be the
higher faculty the understanding is the
the faculty that works with concepts
that that you know if you're calm
projects these categories on to the
world that works with concepts of
objects there's you know there's more to
be said about this you know when we get
to certain things but I don't want to
get it too complicated reason is
something that goes beyond the
understanding and content you know and
this project of a critique of you know
pure reason a critique of practical
reason a critique of judgment you know
critical philosophy was trying to
clarify just what this faculty could in
fact do it was using that faculty in
order to do that that should be a clue
right there the understanding by itself
is not really able to take into account
this entire process so if we think in
terms of consciousness consciousness is
not restricted just to the understanding
if it was we could never formulate
anything beyond the understanding by the
way it's reason that allows us to do
that it's reason that has been operating
behind-the-scenes without us really
realizing at this entire time even in
said certainty but now very definitely
here and so reason is starting to come
on to the scene it's not going to tame
its full scope until the much later
suction that's actually called reason
right we're still exploring the
understanding for the most part but this
is this is working the entire time so
that's something to keep in mind is now
we move into the next sections